welcome to language processing systems a
talk hosted by
pi data so i'll talk a little bit about
pi data and who we are
we're an educational program of num
focus
promoting discussions of best practices
new approaches and emerging technologies
for data management data processing data
analytics
and data visualizations like what we
have today
our guest today is jlmr jay is a machine
learning researcher and engineer
today he'll be giving us a gentle intro
to language models
as well as sharing one of the projects
he has been working on lately
echo and he had just published it
actually
i believe he'll be sharing some features
of echo for the first time here actually
so stay tuned
for questions you can ask them
throughout the talk and jay will be
answering them
in the end jay the mic is
thank you very much um
let me share my screen
okay so this is a gentle a gentle intro
to transformer language models
and that this intro is a little bit
important to make sense of what echo is
so personally i think language models
are
some of the most probably the most
interesting and fascinating technology
out there
i spend so much of my time the last two
three years just thinking about them
and over the last five or six months
i started focusing on them full time and
that's when uh my exploration about how
they work
um it culminated in in some tools that i
put together
and i i released as echo so echo was was
released last week
it's alpha it's a research project it's
an open source project that
um i'd love to to to share with people
and
for people to um contribute to
so we can all understand uh language
models better
um let me just show you
uh the website of
echo so you can go to echox.io
and that's where you'll be able to see
the link to the github
page um and then the article that i
use so i've been doing
writing and research and echo came out
of that research and
this blog post is the first in in a
series
um i'll be releasing the second one
pretty soon at the end of this week or
early next week
and then you can see the features that
that
echo has and we will be covering all of
these now and
some of them are usability or you act
in terms of how you deal with language
models just you know making dealing with
language models a little bit more
accessible
a little easier for people but some of
them are more research oriented
and tackle things like input saliency
and
neuron activations which are which are a
little bit more research topics but
they're
absolutely extremely fascinating
and so we when we talk about open source
we stand on the shoulders of giants
so echo relies on a bunch of tools from
what's called sometimes called the the
pi data stack so it's python
we use numpy jupiter is in there we use
uh psychedelic learn and math clock clip
um we i don't use all of these
tools i just use the ones that we
mentioned and
uh echo is also built on top of pie
torch and hugging face so this is all
open source this is incredible
collaboration of the community
a lot of it is supported by pi data and
num focus and so
um i feel a lot of gratitude to anybody
who
donates to their time their effort to
get open source
um in improving and this is
me thanking all of you
so before we go into it i'd like to make
this a little bit more accessible
to maybe also engineers who haven't
worked with
language models before so i have a
short example that i use to introduce
people
to machine learning so
machine learning is not magic and i use
a small uh
basic example to to illustrate that to
people
so imagine that three people walk into
an ice cream shop
and we want to learn how much or we want
to predict how much they would end up
paying so this is a question that you
can't find the answer to just by
looking at a business book or having an
mba this is a question we can probably
answer with data
and so to answer that we look at the
previous let's say three
transactions that happened in this
ice cream shop the first one had a group
of one person
who end up ended up paying ten dollars
the second one second
transaction was a group of two people
who ended up paying 20
the fourth the third is a group of four
people who ended up paying
40 now we want to predict what three
people would pay
but we don't have data we've never seen
a group of of three people walk into
this high screen
shop before but is there anything we can
glean is there anything we can learn
from the data that we have
that enables us to make that prediction
if you can make that prediction based on
this data set you can type the answer in
the chat
okay yes so 30 30 30. yes everybody's so
i have
three people or four now saying that is
30. exactly so
what you did there that is the central
idea for
machine learning from this is one of the
most basic examples but everything we're
going to be talking about
from alexa to siri to google translate
to even gpt-3
this is the central idea around all of
that they just take it one step
further two steps and three steps and
they keep extending it and so
this gives us a little bit of of the
language to speak about machine learning
and so
what you did is that you found a secret
number that explains the relationship
between these two columns we have the
column on the left
is called our features that's the the
input into our model
the red or pink column is called the
labels that's the
data associated with the value we want
to predict
and then this we can call a labeled data
set this is the historical data set that
we use to make the prediction
and then we have the weights
and so this is the most one of the most
basic uh
machine learning models uh training it
is just finding the number 10. so what
you just did is
you let's say you did the training um
and then to make a prediction you just
give it the input so three you just
multiply
three by ten and then thirty that's
that's the prediction the end so this is
the
simplest machine learning model this is
the simplest neural network
as well it's a neural network of just
with
one weight which is uh 10. and so
training a model is just finding the
right parameters to make to make that
prediction
so data in the real world is not as
friendly we don't have this
clean pattern of everybody walking into
the ice cream shop
actually paying ten dollars um so in the
real world you'll find that you know
three groups each with uh you know one
individual in the group
one would buy for zero one would buy for
twenty dollars one
by four for five um and so
it's difficult to make predictions in a
case like this
so we can extend uh our our example to
say okay can we use more features
so we can break our example into saying
what if we have a group of two adults
and one child
and they walk into an ice cream shop how
much would they pay
and in this case we have let's say four
examples and we have two
features now it's not just the one
column we have the two
feature columns um and so we have
let's say the first one is one child
paid five dollars
the second transaction is one adult paid
ten dollars
uh the third transaction one adult one
child paid fifteen dollars
we've never seen this group of two
adults and one child but
can we make that prediction um can you
if you can figure it out you can type in
the chat
um
25 25 yes that is correct exactly so
you just trained another model in in
your head
another simple model and that model
associates a weight
for each column
and then it says okay 10 times 2 plus
one times five
um and that's 25. and so that's this is
a
neural network let's say of two weights
so this is a little bit more
sophisticated so and so on and so forth
if you have more features more columns
you can
make better predictions and so instead
instead of just the
number of people you can talk about the
temperature the time of day so on so
forth
so the relationship between features and
labels
can be easy or it can be complex based
on the data based on what you want to
predict and so we have
a list of different types of models
that we we can use to to make
predictions
these are some examples from them uh
what we'll be addressing more
here are towards the bottom which is
neural networks
uh there's some examples of neural
networks
um rnns used to be what a lot of natural
language processing
uh was was using uh the transformer
model
has been
eating up nlp and sort of dominating
most of the tasks
in nlp and now it's also doing it seems
to be doing that for computer vision as
well
so when we talk about language modeling
we can think about
[Music]
a feature and and label uh data set
kind of like this where uh one example
is that if we say shawshank we want the
model to predict
redemption because you know the
shawshank redemption is
the the famous movie and story um
and uh yeah great movie um there aren't
many words that usually come
after uh redemption and so if a model
predicts this
um it's it's good and so language models
are trained on data that
is scoured from the internet so we get
all of wikipedia
we get um data from from from elsewhere
and we
break that into examples and then we
train a model against that and you'll
see that
there are some features that like
good um a label can be morning and
could also be evenings because good
morning is a commonly used phrase good
evening is a commonly used phrase
another way where language makes this a
little bit more advanced
is that we're not talking about just one
number or two numbers
um a word is not one input into
a model a word is usually broken down
into what is called an embedding
and so a word is represented by a vector
or a series of numbers
and we have methods uh to turn
words into into embeddings and i can
refer you to my blog there's a post
called the illustrated word to vec about
the model from about 2013
that became very popular so this is
a way for for you to if you haven't been
exposed
to word bettings uh this is probably a
good introduction
so when we talk about language
models and nlp has been doing
incredible things we it might be
it's surprising so if you time travel
somebody from a thousand years ago and
you know you bring them to this age they
would probably be surprised that we
are talking to devices and we're talking
to things and these things are talking
back to us
so we talked with google and siri and
alexa and and
that's incredible technology a lot of it
a lot of us have gotten used to it
uh but it's up it's absolutely amazing
when you
you think about it in just the context
of history
let me show you let me let's take an
exercise as an example
um i'm going to say a word and in the
chat i want you to try to
try to predict what word i'm saying
so this is just an example for how
language models can be helpful
to technologies like like siri so
the word is principle
what do you think that word is is
spelled like can you type in the chat
principle
okay so perfect so we have
two um two answers
and these are the two answers so we have
principal p-l-e
and we have princy pal p-hale and
they're they're
pronounced the same and if you're the
engineer building siri
and that's what that's the only word
that siri heard there isn't really much
you can do but what if you heard it in
in context
that's something a language model can
can really help you with
so what if it's not just a word a
standalone word what if
if it was preceded by these
let's say five words it was a matter of
something
so this is a thing that language models
can can help us with
in terms of really telling us what is
the probability of this word
coming next or the other word from the
next and with that
i will switch to a notebook um
that i will be sharing with you later
where
we can start to see how echo can be
helpful in those in those cases
so
can i see my screen
is the text readable
okay perfect so
when you want to use echo you just do
pip install echo
it's on uh pipe i and then you import it
and then what this does is it creates a
language model it downloads
a trained a pre-trained language model
from
the hugging face package
and so if you have never used a notebook
before these are just cells of code that
we can execute
by just pressing shift enter and this is
running in google collab so you don't
need to set up your
your environment so
here we just load a pre-trained language
model so this is a language model that
has already seen a lot of text
and it was already trained and it knows
a little bit of english
and so with echo we say
this is the input it was a matter of
we pass this to echo and we say okay
generate one word for us
this is generates one token or one word
and uh we want to save that as output
and so when we run this cell
it goes to the language model and the
language model says
time it was a matter of time
so unfortunately it's not principle or
principle we don't know which one yet um
but we can do another thing uh in in
echo
we can say okay this so
this is a view of echo that shows you
the input and
broken down into the tokens that
the language model uh saw and we can see
that the output
position is number five right so there's
zero one two three
four and then this is five so we can say
use echo to say okay in position five
what are their options you outputted
time but to produce time you must have
ranked
uh probabilities for so many words
and so if we run this
uh cell echo would create this
visualization to say okay
at least layer five which is the end of
the model
the token time had 16 percent
probability that's why
it chose but then there are other
possibilities
it could have been let's say it was a
matter of
the or it was a matter of
fact or it was a matter of uh
so these are all possible um
tokens that that could have could have
come um as
the completion uh in that blank it could
have been faith
and then that there is principle ple
and so this is the one that is you know
it's ranked ranked
seven and so what a language model does
here is a language model has knows about
fifty thousand words
this one uh distil uh gpt2
and what it really does is that it gives
a probability score
to each word that it knows um and they
here they add up to uh to one
and so then we can if we're generating
text we can just
select the highest probability word or
we have other methodologies of what it
is what's called
decoding these are decoding strategies
another thing we can do to explore this
using echo is to say okay
let's get the token ids of the two words
that we're interested in
and so these are the two numbers of
token ids and i
plug them here and this is another
method
in inside of echo that will be in the
blog post that i'll be publishing and
this compares principle with principal
so it was a matter of blank and then
in this what word could have come in
this blank principle was
at the end of the model was ranked
number seven so it was the
seventh highest ranking word but this
one principle
pal was one thousand six hundred uh so
it was not even close
so the model is is fairly certain that
it is principle like this
so this is a graph that you can use to
see what
words that you're interested in could
have been filled
this is matplotlib and
seaborn on top of it um so yes this is a
seaborn heat map with with some um
hello vincent uh
tweaking and the the color uh there's
some
tweaking for for the color uh here and
how that's
shown
and so this is um just a quick look
um at
overview let's say of echo and we'll go
back but we'll talk about language
models a little bit more and then come
back and so
this is um a visual of what we can say
um
we did with the model we so we presented
this
uh these four tokens it was a matter of
to a transformer and um
it goes through the layers and
we we get the outputs after afterwards
and so that's that's the demo that we
the quick demo that we just
went into um
i'm i understand the the importance of
things by looking at applications
and i want to talk about uh applications
of language models
that are probably around you so let's
say you go to google to search something
let's say you search you're interested
in siri and series technology and you
search for siri tech and then you have
your your recommendations kind of like
this
and then you
have a search result kind of like this
so this is these are just
screenshots for me from my phone you
click on this
uh search result and then you have uh
the result highlighted like this i don't
know if you've come across this
highlighting
yet but it's you know for me it's it's
sorry it's uh
i can see it so
which one of these steps do you think um
[Music]
uses aaa language models um if you can
post that in the chat
i would so step one is searching step
two
is the this search result in step three
is actually
uh clicking on on the result so which of
these three steps
if you can type in the chat which step
do you think used a language mod
oh all three okay so this is pretty
unanimous that all three have used
language models and
you're actually correct so it's not just
three
um i kind of pricked you here it's there
are
about at least five usages of language
models here
so the the suggestions
that google is is presenting to you
that's most likely something like a
language model
the suggestions the autocomplete by the
keyboard
is the most used language model that all
of us use
hundreds maybe thousands of times a day
this
is also an application of language
models the highlighting is another one
there's a step 1.5 between one and two
that also uses language models
ah old words that's probably also
so okay so now we have six uh uses um so
the first one is autocomplete or
predicting the next word
that is is using language models in step
one
and step two this um
summary is a summary let's say of of the
wikipedia page so that's text
summarization that uses
uh i can assure you that it uses
transformer language models to do this
um the highlighting is question
answering
um and so that's another technology that
uses uh
language modeling highlighting the the
words is probably
it could be a language model but it
could be also just um
string matching
yes the first one could be a character
level language model
there's a step 1.5 between them that
right now google is using
bert in all of its search results and so
when
you submit a a query in all of their
english
when you submit a query they use a
language model to try to
not just search for the words but the
meaning behind the words
and this is an example from a post that
they've published before
where if somebody searches 2019 brazil
traveler to usa
before using bert they would give you
this answer on the left
where it has all of the keywords but
it's somebody traveling
to brazil not to usa but then after
using bert
search is now able to
understand let's say quote-unquote the
meaning behind
the the sentence a lot better and the
quality of search has improved
a lot better than just matching the
keywords and strings
if you use gmail you probably come
across these suggestions um
at the bottom which are response
selection
and this is a technology or a use case
of of
uh language models that you can also
find in conversational agents as a whole
uh siri or you know chat bots
things like raza all of that is response
selection
um and that is definitely based on
language models
so this is just to say that language
models are all around you
you either realize it or i hope you're
realizing it now
and they're really changing the
landscape of you know what technologies
are
being able to so i think it's a very
important uh
tool in the toolbox of any engineer to
really try to understand what language
models are doing
and how they work uh a word on training
a language model
what is most commonly done now is a
two-step
way of of training these models and so
we can do
pre-training which is a language model
which is just predicting the next word
so we get a lot of text
from the the internet and we train a
model to be able to predict that next
word
once we do that the model turns out to
encode a lot of
knowledge about the world and knowledge
about language
and then we can take it a little bit
more training to
fine-tune it to be able to to solve a
different task
a word on pre-training so
this is an example of
training let's say or pre-training the
model in the beginning so we give it
three words and we know what the
completion should be
the model is not trained so it will
output
a junk result we know that
it's wrong we can calculate how wrong it
was we
back propagate that so this is the the
loop of machine learning and training
models as a whole and
so we do this thousands of times um
and then we have a trained language
model and that's this the first step of
pre-training
once we do that it's just training it
for a little bit more
for it to be able to solve one of the
other problems
okay so that's a quick overview about
applications
of of language models um
let me show you a couple of things that
i thought were interesting
while exploring some language models so
i said that language models not only
capture
language but they also capture some some
world
knowledge so if we tell a language model
uh to complete this sentence
if we say heathrow airport is located in
black would it be able to
really guess that we wanted to say
london
or not so we can ask it to generate five
words or five tokens and it would say
it's at the heart of this city well we
can't say that this is a
wrong answer uh
it's perfectly acceptable unfortunately
it's not what we were looking for
we were trying to probe so we can say
okay let's change our input problem
a little bit to say heathrow airport is
located
in the city of and will not be able to
really probe
the model to give us a city or not and
so we ask it to generate one word
and here it says is located in the city
of
london so this is you know a successful
um question is it is it based on the
data that the model is trained on yes
so this is a pre-trained model trained
on a lot of data
collected from from the internet and you
just you don't need to train it you just
download it and you can
play around with it and explore it
generate five on the second so yes
that is a request from the chat you can
generate five and echo would show you
so it's just london period
so let's send it back to one and because
i want to show you something else
so we we saw the predicted words in the
previous example
what other predictions are are possible
here for london
so london is the first or top uh token
with 13 percent
but could also have said birmingham
manchester glasgow edinburgh all cities
notice
in all british or uk
or english cities
in england and around you can change
this top k to say you know if you want
to look
because the model has already scored 50
000 words
so you can say okay you show me maybe 30
different
predictions you will get some from
ireland
westminster and then you get these
partial so the models are not only
outputting
words they can also output tokens which
are part of words
so it can be same or in something else
and you can see the ranking of each
token but also the
um probability that the model has
so another thing that's also interesting
is rankings so if you
tell the output just to output to
rankings
this model we said is six layers
the top the the last layer is the one
that ranked
london first so we can see throughout
while the
model was processing
this input what each layer ranked the
token london has
and so at the end of layer 0 it was
ranked 800. layer one is 270. so you can
see the layers are slowly
elevating the ranking and the
probability of the word london until the
last
layer really says that okay this is the
answer and
we just pick the top one as our and so a
lot of this
uh type of visualization is inspired by
this
incredible blog post uh called
interpreting gpt
the the logit lens uh by
uh the nostalgia brist i don't know we
have a name for
him or her so check that out it's it's
absolutely incredible
um and a lot more will be coming about
this in the coming um
upcoming blog post uh
one thing here is since we're talking
about
at completion let me see what my next
slides
are okay yes we're good so
this i love this um prompt
uh and giving it to gpt
let's say the countries of the european
union are newline
one dot australia two belgium three
bulgarian so i want
before asking this or seeing the output
of the model there are a few questions
can the model continue i understand that
there's a list and continue numbering it
correctly
can it follow the same formatting that
we used here
then is it able to actually name
countries and european ones
um and will let's notice that they are
alphabetical
or not and so this is the the prompt and
we tell the model to generate
20 and we ask it to sample so not just
to pick the highest
[Music]
scoring token
so echo will show you the output as the
model
generates it and so this is where the
output starts
uh at the arrows and so the model is
saying okay croatia
new line five denmark estonia
finland so you can see the numbering is
continued
the periods are are there it's the same
sort of formatting it is this is c
d e f it is also alphabetical these are
all countries
and uh it stops so that's that's 20
tokens
and so that's you know this is that is
still gpt model
and i like this because it it shows you
know a few things and
we'll get into that a little bit i
showed you
the ranking for london here so we can
actually
see or graph the ranking for
all of the tokens that the model output
and that's what we'll do
is that not beautiful so
look at the patterns here there are some
some columns that are generally pink
and that's the new line um
and the period so from layer 0
the model very early on realizes what
this
output token should be like so the
earlier layers are able to notice that
okay yes
now we're going to put a new line or or
or a period
for the numbers so this is 5 6 this is a
7.
they tend to be resolved it's a round
layer three and then the layer
four really elevates that token so you
can say that
maybe layers three and four really are
the ones that
um have a sense of which numbers
come after each other and it's easy to
be to confuse yourself to by thinking
that the model knows numbers the model
just knows tokens
so it just knows that five is probably
uh a token that usually would come after
four
you see that the the words the
actual list items the country names are
usually resolved towards the end
they need a lot of the models um let's
say representational
capacity to be able to be resolved
we chose one in almost all of them
but then here we chose the fifth highest
ranking
one which was denmark that is because we
said
do sample here so it just picks based on
the probability it will
picks from the top 50 uh tokens
and it just gives us interesting results
this way
and so this is the type of visualization
that i that i really love and it just
tells you about about the the various
uh layers uh and you can take that to
bigger models and smaller models and
different kinds
of input and to look at that so a lot of
this is
based on the incredible work by the
nostalgia boost
so one of the main features in in the
literature of of
um explainability and interpretability
in machine learning
uh input saliency is is one thing that
is uh
is used and so we can uh use that or
have a view for that here
what this says is that the darker the
color is
off off of the token the more that token
had
uh we attribute that
to the outputting of this token and so
when the model was creating
croatia the tokens that had the most
um let's say attribution to actually how
generate that token are bulgaria and
austria
um and maybe the countries so i was
thinking about about countries
um you can this is an interactive
visualization so you can go here and see
the new line
is the new lines are usually the model
focuses
on the token preceding it to maybe
get the sense that the word is is done
or complete
the numbering the model looks at the
generally tends to look at the previous
numbers and the previous list item
so this is a simplified view and then
you can also have the detailed view that
will show you
exact numbers and so when you're moving
over the names of the countries you can
see that these
um lines these let's say call them spark
bars
um are indicating that the list items is
are the ones most responsible for the
model generating risks
outputs the same thing with the numbers
the model sort of
attributes this to to looking at the
previous numbers
and when you're on the new lines it
tends to always
almost always look at the previous token
so this can be overlapped a little bit
with
um with attention and
i'm working on things that sort of um
compare and contrast uh and put saliency
to attention
and so this leaves us with one um
last major feature uh in echo to discuss
but before we do that um we need to uh
just introduce a little bit more of
detail about
the models so a transformer language
model we showed that
it has a number of decoder blocks or
layers
and we saw the model with six layers
the each layer has two major components
and each of these components has we can
say a general
rule the first major component is the
feedforward neural network and that is
the the
component that is able to generally tell
or
encode what words tend to come after
previous words and so
when we say shar the feed forward neural
network is the one that is gonna
uh predict that probably redemption is
is is the following group so this is the
one major component of the decoder layer
it's not the only one the other one is
self-attention so
we looked at this example in the
beginning it was a matter of
so if we only had a feed for a neural
network
it will only be able to tell us what
words usually come
after of and that would not always be
helpful because that does not have
context self-attention is able to bake
the representations and the
understanding and the meaning of
all of the tokens before
uh the word that we're currently
processing and so these two working
together
they're the ones that that empower these
transformer layers and they're the ones
that empower
incredible applications like gpd3 and
birth and everything we see in nlp and
so these are the two major components
there's a lot of work visualizing
self-attention or attention
um so i i haven't uh
done much of that i have some ideas and
some things that i might roll out in the
future
but i would like to refer you to expert
it's an incredible
visualization portal where you can input
some tokens and choose a model it will
visualize self-attention for you
so that i did not work on but i did work
on
uh the feed-forward neural network and
that's our last
view that we will be looking at if you'd
like a little bit more
understanding about the components of
the transformer i'd love to
refer you to my blog post the
illustrated transformer
and with that we can do our demo of
amateur brain surgery
and this one you can find
here so this is the notebook that we'll
be going over
so it's in the echo x that i o and then
you can
click on this collab and it will open up
the notebook for you and you can start
experimenting with it right away
and i don't know if i run this before
but what this does
is install
echo
i did not yet write a there's a question
that did i write the paper that presents
the library not yet i'm doing that right
now right now it's
it's a blog post but there's hopefully
going to be something
a little bit more formal
so we've installed echo and then we can
download the model
so you can also try different models by
the way so you can this can also be
maybe gpt too for a bigger model with
with different
uh results
and so what this does is this would
download the the hugging face a trained
model
it's about 300 megabytes
and then we have this text that we
present to the model
and we say just generate one token
because we don't really care about what
you're
going to generate we just want to
understand your
react to this text
and so here the model is processing this
it outputs some token but we don't
really
care about that it says so so now
what we have is so outputs
now has a variable called activations
that stores all the activations of the
neurons inside the feedforward neural
network
and has the this shape and so the model
has
six layers and so that's the first
dimension here each layer of distilled
gpt2 has
3072 neurons
and the length of this text is 354
um let's say tokens
and so this is the activations
vector here you can visualize it i think
i still have some some visualizations
methods uh for activations uh but it's
it's a little noisy so one incredible
way to shrink down that noise and get
some signal out of it
is to do um dimensionality reduction
using something called non-negative
matrix factorization
and that's what we do here it says okay
take these
activations and
break them down into
ten components there's a
question here from vincent gotta ask
what front end are you using here is
this custom d3 rendered as html in the
notebook
or are they ipi widgets this is
um d3 custom d3
rendered so echo is actually two things
it's a python library but it's also
echo js a javascript library they're
separate repositories both are open
source and
it uses both both of them to actually
output output
and so this is the the output of
exploring this to
to the 10 and here we can see
um you know it broke down
six times three thousand is about
eighteen thousand
uh neuron activations um into ten
different factors the first factor
highlights
this so there tends to be neurons that
focus on
the word vat and
a second factor second pattern in the
activation
uh tends to be let's say i'm running out
of ram a little bit
okay he he man really so this is one way
to
to look at this what i really love
is this when we look at the only the
first layer so we can say okay break it
down into
ten components and these uh
neurons of the first layer let's try to
find
the underlying
patterns in in their activation and
that's what we have here
so we have there are groups of neurons
that tend to activate
towards the middle of the text which is
very interesting because
these tokens they don't really have a
signal um about
their location uh except for the the
positional encoding and so that really
tells us about
neurons that are um sensitive to
potentially to uh positional encodings
we have three of these
so we have a factor for the middle we
have a factor towards the end
and we have a factor towards the
beginning the focus on various
uh parts of the text
we have a factor that says that of
neurons that
only focus or focus very intently on the
first token and this is common to gpt it
is less of a factor in invert but
echo so far only focuses on
uh gpt for now but then look at this
do you see a pattern in these words
highlighted by factory number five
uh these are all pronouns
these are all maybe let's say commas but
this is
you know punctuation but here you're
starting to see some some linguistic
properties that are being able to were
split
splitting out um from the activations of
the models and so this is will would
shall um
and other verbs here um
r is and so you can you can change the
the number of components you can try
less or more and
if you anything you you find interesting
i love you posted to the discussions but
this is one of the earlier
places where i um
and so this i think this concludes my
talk
let me see if i can address some of the
questions
let's see okay yes
so uh please remind me if i've missed
any of the questions
previously so i see will it be useful to
create everything from scratch for
intuition or high-level idea for that
concept would work not unders
standing exactly so
i find it useful to just use a
pre-trained model so you don't have to
train your own model
um hugging face makes that a lot easier
but you can try bigger models i don't
know if that answers
your questions um
you can you can elaborate on on the
question
um vincent about the front end
uh it seems to incrementally update is
there also a server running
sending data to
[Music]
uh javascript so yes
um every time the model gen
so there are two updates
[Music]
so these updates are all on on
javascript
so the python backend has given
the javascript package everything that
needs all the tokens or their
activations
so all of this shifting here happens on
the javascript side
when you're outputting a token kind of
like this
a the python sort of back end
keeps invoking the javascript and say
god we have a new token
displayed we have a new token please
display it
lex is asking will it guess the
alphabetical order for countries in
reverse
i'd love for you to try that and let me
know in twitter
um and i'm
intrigued to to to learn
that um marit is asking how can we use
impotency for some of the dance
stream um nlp tasks
so the one of the best tools that people
can use now is captum
it needs a little bit of of work and i'm
working on
um a way to try to do input saliency for
bert and maybe some downstream
but it's it's it's not not that
difficult to just
back propagate back propagating the
gradient and then just multiplying it by
the
um let's say the input uh embedding
so it's kind of one line but it's it's
that that back prop
but for now maybe the best tool to do
that is captain
c a in the example
listing in the countries in the eu what
mechanisms
prevents answers from being repeated
that is
a great question and that is why i told
them
the model to do sample is
uh true so if we say false it will
always
choose the highest ranking token
just number one and that would
tend to make it less interesting i would
think
i tend to repeat czech republic
uh but it will probably yeah see it just
repeats it but if we say if we set this
to true
see it just repeats i mean still
continuing to count but and then if we
plot the
rankings here you'll see the difference
between the two
is that it's always selecting the top
one
and so check is one one one one while
here it's more interesting because it
was able to
select the fifth token
vincent are there updates going from
javascript to python
no no it's all one way so far
i think yes um
one question next word prediction result
already in
the training set um
yeah so the training set is uh
extracting a lot of next word prediction
examples
uh from real world texts so that's
that's the
language modeling task that these models
are trained on
uh what are the libraries um saying
to you
so i linked to a number of uh nlp
visualization
libraries in in the blog post i think
that's probably the best
resource a captain does saliency
um there's a bunch of them based on so
expert i've already mentioned
um and then captain has some some
visualizations as well
in the pokemon union i don't know give
me something and i'll i'll plug it into
the model
what problems of ai do you think
transformers has shown significant
progress in um i assume knowledge
representation because of their ability
to represent
and recognize entities and abstract
concepts and relate them with each other
so in the beginning
transformers were used because they can
be trained in parallel
in a way that is uh a lot easier to do
than rnns
but then with time they were able to
[Music]
dominate the the let's say the
the benchmark or set top of the charts
in in every
different task so they're able to train
large models
uh on vast amount of data and the bigger
you keep the
make the models the more they will they
will learn um
and so that's that's a little bit of why
they tend to be used
um would this nmf reduction method work
for
other types of input sequences of data
token
speech yes i can see why not and i'm
interested to try other ways of
dimensionality reduction i first started
out with pca
uh but with pca it's difficult to
interpret the negative
dimension of pca but nmf is is
is pretty fascinating
would this also support language models
trained on massive language modeling
objective like pert and not
autoregressive models like gpt
i'm working on that so that's hopefully
in the roadmap it's
it's not supported yet
to what extent can echo allow us to
explain why a language model has made a
particular prediction
increase the interpretability of such a
model so
it just provides a couple of of tools
um that you know one could could add to
their toolbox it's not
the only uh one out there and it's still
a sort of a research
project
um so yes saliency is an explainability
method
um but i'm also interested too to
explore
neuron activations for that as well
we have the nmf uh projection
visualization of the contextual license
space in three dimensions for
an intuitive understanding um yes
i think so
um
[Music]
yeah i think there's a lot we can do
with that i haven't wrapped my head
exactly around around this use case
but but let me uh think about it a
little bit
can the visualization highlight biases
encoding in the language model
yes thank you for answering this i have
an example but i don't know if i have it
out
so um
okay we'll do this live and we'll maybe
close with this
so you see this visualization uh we can
use this to maybe probe
for bias in language
so we can say
the text is
the doctor was uh
and then we wanted to generate
and token
and i don't know if you can see what's
gonna happen here or not
the doctor was a doctor okay sure that's
why not
but then we can use this kind of uh
probing to say okay give us the
man and woman tokens
and then watch out
for these two tokens
how did they rank i guess
nope yeah i'll put one
okay so we just need to change the
position position here is four
so this would be four
and so you can see the doctor was a man
the word man in all of the layers had a
higher ranking
than woman as the word to fill in this
space
but then we can say the nurse
was a
okay nurse then we don't need to change
this but then the visualization
here would say the nurse was a
woman ranked higher than man here it
ranked number eight
while man did 22. but that only happened
at the last
layer every layer before ranked man
before
or higher than so this is a kind of
way to sort of explore uh biases that i
found
interesting
yep i think that
concludes it um
thank you very much please check out
echo let me know how i can prove it
you're welcome to uh help me um